let's talk about Hollywood and Hillary
and racism because as we all know
racism's epicenter is the Oscars and
Hillary Clinton oh wait that's the crazy
haha but hey wait is it clearly okay but
well they got part of race she is white
it's great it is a little crazy that the
the protests I see have to do with the
Oscars and with Hillary Clinton a black
lives matter protesters interrupted
Hillary at a fundraiser and said Hillary
Clinton can you apologize to black
people for mass incarceration I you know
of the thousand things I could complain
about with Hillary Clinton being a
racist really doesn't rise to the top of
it I mean it's she's all get any new
politics but it sure is fun being purer
than everybody else right does this
person realize that Donald Trump in
South Carolina 20% of the voters who
voted for Donald Trump disagree with the
Emancipation Proclamation right and this
is who you're going after this is where
we start the battle you [ __ ] idiot
bill I don't think they were call it
let's let's be fair just like when Kanye
West said George Bush doesn't care about
black people he didn't call more races
although George Bush heard races they
not they're not claiming as the black
lives matter that Hillary is a racist
what they're saying is that negative
racial consequences flowed from mass
incarceration and by the way when they
accused her of talking about the super
predator which she did let's note the
fact she apologized when Bernie Sanders
taken out of country but now in the
second saying black people are predators
no no she was saying super predators the
language that John DeLucie or somebody
was using about black criminals in a
second but here's my point just she had
leading apologized and acknowledged that
that was a problem but I'm saying I
think it's sexist for people to impute
to Hillary Clinton what our husband did
her husband was the President of the
United States of America
not him record
right now now but I'm not mad at anyone
but one party does not even acknowledge
that racism even exists they say it's an
urban myth no no you're right I see that
show what the black lives matter
implicitly are proving the humanity of
the Democrats because at least they're
humane enough to respond in kind to them
the the Republicans don't give a flying
a damn about what's going on there and
therefore they prove their inhumanity so
in one sense they are affirming it and
the current Bush is a party the party
that has supported the party that was
supposed to be for the for black people
right has let them down continuously and
that's what the black lives matter
absolutement is going after the
Democrats because they're the ones who
are supposed to be on the starting their
jigging the program of publican take
women taking them for granted to look
like but as a person as a person who
believes that Hillary Clinton will be
the next president of the United States
of America I'm telling you from a
sympathetic position it is there is no
problem with black lives matter
challenging them because the Democrats
have had a history as brother Ruffalo is
saying of exploiting those black people
but at the end of the day I think that
Hillary Clinton is not only the smartest
person the most prepared person but the
person who has given the most credible
empirical analysis of race in the last
twenty years by a major American
politician I'll stand
SME is great
people need to learn the difference
between an imperfect friend and a deadly
enemy no day I want to tear Hillary
Clinton down great
then enjoy president Trump you only get
two choices in America right two choices
but it's perfectly legitimate to keep
black lives matter at the forefront of
what people are thinking about right
because if you're not there showing your
issue someone else is there instead
right and I think you know it was
unfortunate the way she did it but at
least she had been allowed into
Hillary's thing you can imagine that she
would have been blocked from trumps all
the way around on the crowd she's the
only black person there when you get
$500 a plate fundraiser is coming why is
that a problem
it's do they have to be everywhere
giving you money who's there the black
people really I can't
yeah we should be everywhere if we said
I don't know I can't use the term today
when I head that makes me a racist come
on bill yeah I'm the problem - no no no
okay not at all but what I'm saying
reacted when I said they no no no I
didn't react that was not me bro that me
a white guy okay but we all look like
Billy
actually I'm sympathetic to you in terms
of the argument about the efficacy of
race what you're arguing about if I can
if I can dare to speak for you is that
let's be politic and strategic about
getting even our friends who have made
mistakes who are imperfect to do the
things we want them to do let's not
close them down so much because if you
keep practicing the politics of
disruption to the degree that they don't
get a chance to respond then that's
counterproductive however the reason
we're talking about this today is
because they have been effective in
forcing a conversation that we'd rather
avoid but at the end of the day I'm
rolling with HRC to the end because I
think she give a serious indication of
what's happening in this country
racially so we can have black lives
matter articulating their concerns and
Hillary Clinton responding to them
better by the way than the occupant of
the White House and others who claim to
be the Friends of African American
people as well okay